Das Podcast-Ufo, dass du mit dabei seid. Bei der Ausgabe der Verteidigung von Tietze. Wow, und das waren Pau da und Jo. Vielen Dank für dieses fantastische Intro, mit dem ihr uns direkt in die Folge katapultiert. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Sehr schön. Vielen, vielen Dank. Das war sehr lustig, das war sehr, sehr cool, das war sehr professionell, das war richtig toll.
Wir haben lange geschlafen, wir sind aufgeweckt, wir sind vollgepumpt mit Koffein, Adrenalin und all den schönen Dingen, die das Leben lebenswert machen.
Okay, okay, pass auf, sag mir drei Filme, die es nicht gibt.
Der Tanz der Wölfe.
Zwei.
Die Schlümpfe Teil acht.
Okay, drei. Und The Fast and the friendly. Nice. Fast and friendly. Super. Es geht darum, um Rentner-Ehepaar, das nicht mehr weiss, was es tun soll, es hat zu viel Zeit, also entscheidet es sich, Leuten in der Umgebung zu helfen, in der Stadt. Und man dann sagt so, ah, lass uns doch mal gucken, was haben die anderen Menschen so für Probleme und dann gehen die denen zur Hand und helfen denen so und dann wollen dann sagen die, ah, ja, wir wollen ja noch die, wir bringen die Tochter von den Heinrichsens, bringen wir zum Ballettunterricht, aber dann finden die keinen Parkplatz. Dann finden die keinen Parkplatz, sondern gucken die hier links und dann, weil die ziemlich schnell unterwegs sind. Wir haben ... Nee, pass auf, pass auf, okay, noch mal zurück. Es geht los mit einer Super-Hyper-Gameshow. Hey Leute, ruft an, klingelt durch, heute zu gewinnen ein Mustang-Sportwagen, 500 PS, super krass, klingelt durch und dann ruft an, ja, hallo, hier ist die Renate, das Lösungswort ist Capoeira. Ah ja, völlig richtige Antwort, Capoeira ist das Lösungswort. Zack, der Mustang geht an Renate. Frage, warum wusste Renate von Capoeira? Weil Renate jeden Tag diese Sendung schaut, jeden Tag. Quizshow ist ihre Lieblingssendung. Capoeira! Und jetzt hat Renate diesen krassen Sportwagen und macht damit halt normale Alltagsbesorgungen, fährt damit in der Stadt. Cool. Weil es ist halt einfach ihr Auto. Ihr altes Auto hat sie damals verloren im Krieg, da ist eine Bombe. Im Krieg genau draufgefallen. Die Bombe ist nicht echt verliert. Genau, ein Blindgänger ist auf ihr Auto aufgefallen und dann konnte sie sich nie wieder ein Auto leisten bis zu diesem tag wo sie the fast and the friendly geworden ist und dann nimmt der der film aber eine wendung weil sie finden keinen parkplatz mit diesem riesen schiff mit diesem riesen schiff finden sie keinen parkplatz das ist generell meine idee für neues horrorgenre alltags horror erwachsenen horror weil es gibt so viele Dinge, wo ich mir wirklich denke, oh Gott, bitte, bitte nicht. Und das in einem Horrorfilm würde ich gerne mal sehen. Also wirklich, du stehst am Bahnsteig, Zug hat eh schon Verspätung und dann einfach noch um zehn Minuten weiter verspätet, Gleiswechsel. Und dann aber genau die Musik, die man im Horrorfilm hätte, so ein Jumpscare, er guckt erst nicht hin und dann geht das Handy und dann rot.
Und dann das vierte rote Ausrufezeichen bei der Bahn. Oder man findet ewig keinen Parkplatz hin und ist da einer, ah nee, ist eine Einfahrt, Ausfahrt, geht da einer raus. Dieser Horror auf dem Baumarktparkplatz zu fahren und dann ist es rechts, links, rechts, links, alles voll, voll, man nähert sich langsam dem Ende, voll, voll, voll, voll, voll. Ja, Horror. So könnte man doch wirklich mal einen Horrorfilm machen.
Nee, sie haben den falschen Anmeldeschein für ihren neuen Ausweis dabei. So ein Double-Take. So ein Double-Take. Sie hatten doch gesagt, wenn ich um 12 Uhr hier bin mit meinem, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din, din,lich, weil du die Vorstellung, dass, keine Ahnung, es war eine Kurzfilmeidee eher.
Also eine kleine Idee für einen kleinen Film.
Für einen ganz ganz kleinen Film. Kleine Idee für einen kleinen Film.
Okay.
Und da wollte ich dich fragen, ob du, weil es ist eh basierend auf dir, dich, wie auch immer deutsch funktioniert, und da habe ich überlegt, wie wäre es denn, wenn du quasi dich selber spielst, jemand, der super angenervt ist, von jemandem im Ruhrabteil spricht, im Kino spricht, eigentlich Leute, die sprechen, im Weg stehen, genau, vor Rolltreppen stehen bleiben oder sowas, aber du bringst die Leute dann um. Du verfolgst die und bringst die um. Oft dann aber mit dem, was sie nicht oder zu viel getan haben. Passende Morde und es geht halt so ein Serienmörder um und man fragt sich,
was passiert hier, wer bringt diese ganzen
Menschen um und dann findet man heraus,
ah, es sind Menschen, die sich davor
in alltäglichen Situationen
nicht so gut und dann eben wieder, es gibt so einen
jungen Detektiv, der
für das Haus. Okay, wir gehen nochmal durch,
weil something doesn't have here.
Was ist hier, was ist da was jetzt? Sympathische Figur. Was ist da was hier? Ich glaube, irgendwas ist hier weird. Irgendwas ist hier sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr creepy. Irgendwas ist hier creepy. Irgendwas ist hier so creepy und weird. Ja, so ein Sympathismus. Anglizismus der Film. Anglizismus weirdo. It somehow doesn't add up here. Er war erst in der Hauptstrasse und dann in der Meissnerstrasse. Irgendwas ist hier weird, irgendwas ist hier echt strange. Irgendwas ist hier erfüllt.
I got to connect the clues. Oh Gott. Ich habe nur eins gefunden, weil ich dachte, der heisst irgendwie so James Webster. Okay. Okay. Okay, wir sind auch nicht. Ich mag auch, dass du bei deinen Filmen wirklich erstmal die absolut wichtigsten Dinge festlegst. Name der Hauptfigur, Farbe der Krawatte, genau, Farbe des Plakats und Musik, jede Musik penibel pro Sekunde rausgehört, aber was genau passiert, weil zum Beispiel, wie findet der Detective raus, dass das Opfer immer bei der Rolltreppe im Weg statt? Pass auf, er sagt dann so, irgendwas macht dir keinen Sinn, wir müssen nochmal den Zeitstrahl. Susan, Susan, Susan, give me the timeline, give me the sagt, wir sind einfach fucking, wir arbeiten in Bottrop, ich verstehe nicht, warum du redest. Nee, nee, sorry, Entschuldigung, so, aber sag noch genau, wir müssen die Dots connecten, die was, die Punkte verbinden, naja, jedenfalls, sag mir noch mal, wo die Familie genau war, waren die, wo war die Familie? Ja? Die Familie, die komplett gestorben ist. Ach so, die waren am Bahnhof. Und dann, wo sind sie dann, mit welchem Zug sind sie gefahren? Sie sind im Bahnhof, im ICE 2084. Wo haben sie gesessen? Wir müssen alles wissen, wo haben sie gesessen? Aha, sie haben im Ruheabteil gesessen. Eine Familie im Ruheabteil. Mit zwei Kindern. Moment, warum soll man im Ruheabteil sitzen, something doesn't add up here. Also irgendwas ergibt dir keinen Sinn. Ich habe es schon verstanden. Wir arbeiten seit einigen Wochen miteinander. Ja, weil ich den Augenrollen sehe. Naja, weil es einfach nervt, weil es einfach nervt, weil du es einfach auf Deutsch sagen kannst, weil ich schon verstehe, was es ist. Ich sehe das Cringe und Eyerolls. Woran hast du gemerkt, dass ich cringe? Ein Callback zur letzten Folge. Korrekt deswegen müsste ein bisschen ihr müsst ein bisschen
wach sein müssen wir haben die letzte folge direkt vor der neuen folge bis alles kein win
so ja welche idee gefällt euch besser the fast Fast and the Friendly oder Pedant? Wie heisst der Film? Pedant. Pedant. The Pedant. Pedant. Steht auch genau, wie man es ausspricht. Ist es nicht sogar auf so einem Albumcover von Leonard Skinner, dass sie unter ihren Namen geschrieben haben, wie man ihn ausspricht? Ist das cool oder ist das ein bisschen verzweifelt, wo man das Gefühl hat, niemand spricht uns richtig aus, wir müssen Leonard Skinner, Leonard Skinner, wir müssen das drunter schreiben, weil es einfach niemand checkt. Ist es, findest du es okay oder findest du es petty? Ich finde das völlig furchtbar. Leonard Skinner ist ja schon ein ausgedachter Name. Dann denk dir doch, wenn dein Problem, dann ist erwartbar. Die können sich aussprechen, denk dir doch noch, wie der Name aussehen oder aussprechen kann. Wie Thales. Was ist Thales? Thales ist dieser Zug, der durch Belgien, Luxemburg, Deutschland und Frankreich fährt. Und die brauchten einen Namen. Ja, oder Bob, die bayerische Oberlandbahn. Bob. Ja, aber das ist ja ja, nee, ich meine ja so, es gibt das in jedem Land verständlich. Alle lesen es gleich, alle sprechen es gleich aus. Egal ob du Franzose, Deutscher oder Belgier bist, du weisst Thales ist Thales. Alle sagen Thales. Ja, Thales ist Thales. Auch die Franzosen sagen Thales. Die können es nicht anders aussprechen. D'Alice. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Non, ce n'est pas possible. Thales. We are Delice. Und deswegen haben die es ausgesucht, die brauchen ein Wort, was alle verstehen, gleich aussprechen. Das wäre gut. Okay, gut. Naja. Ich bin gerade ein bisschen im Stress. Ich habe ein bisschen so ein Hobbystress, also so ein Freizeitstress jetzt gelandet, weil ich bin in einer Music League. Ich weiß nicht, ob du von dieser App mitbekommen hast. Musik League. Musik League. Ach so, League. Musik. Liga. Liga. Genau, League. Und die Idee dieser App, und die finde ich fantastisch, ist glaube ich nicht so mega bekannt, ich weiß nicht wie viral das gerade ist, glaube ich nicht so ein mega Phänomen, aber ein paar andere machen es, die ich kenne und da bin ich jetzt auch in einer Liga gelandet. Die Idee ist, dass es als Add-on von Spotify funktioniert und du hast beispielsweise Kategorien wie, ich weiss nicht, einen Song, den du niemals mit deinen Eltern hören solltest oder der beste Song aus dem Jahre 2003 oder ein guter Song mit deutschen deutschen lyrics oder sowas und diese kategorien und dann musst du einen song einreichen mit dem spotify link es funktioniert als addon von spotify und du machst dann spotify link da rein und reichst dann sozusagen deinen song ein und die idee ist ein bisschen herauszufinden wer von den freunden hat den besten musikgeschmack findet also immer den besten für die beste Kategorie. Denn dann hast du einen Einreichungszeitraum, dann, wenn alle eingereicht haben, kriegst du eine Playlist mit all diesen Songs, was sehr cool ist, weil du hast immer eine Playlist, die du hören kannst. Songs, die ich nicht mit meinen Eltern hören will, kannst du dir schön einfach auf eine Zugfahrt reinballern. Ja, genau, das ist ein bisschen schwierig, aber, weiss nicht, jetzt waren neich Workout-Songs und so, das macht dann schon Spaß. Wenn Leute coole energetic Songs haben, energiereich, ja, sorry, ich will mir auch vor, weniger in Englisch scheiße sprechen. Du, ist in Ordnung, ich hab da keinen Trouble mit. Und dann ist es total spannend, weil was jetzt passiert ist, dann die Voting-Phase. Oder anonymisiert, hoffe ich. Anonymisiert, nicht anonymisiert. Nicht anonymisiert? Nein. Okay, das heißt. Man sieht danach, wer was gut fand, ja. Aber du kannst jetzt nicht immer für Anna stimmen. Nee, doch, kann man schon. Ach so, du siehst, warum? Nee, nee, man sieht nicht, wer den Song eingereicht hat. Ah, also doch anonymisiert. Nee, dein Voting ist nicht anonymisiert. Die Songs sind anonymisiert eingereicht, das heißt, ist die Frage, was du meinst. Man sieht danach, wer für was gestimmt hat. Okay, blind. Blind stimmen. Blind stimmen. Genau, du weißt nicht, für wen du abstimmst. Ja, so wie bei der demokratischen Wahl, wo du ein Kreuz machst, aber du weißt nicht, bei welcher Partei das ist. Die sind geschwärzt, die Parteien sind geschwärzt, du siehst nur die Liste. Es ist exakt, und danach sieht man, wer für welche Partei er gestimmt hat. Genau. Weil er aber nicht wusste, von wem es ist. Es ist genau wie Demokratie. Genau, es ist genau so. Du machst ein Kreuz und dann weisst du aber nicht genau wofür, damit es anonym ist. Immer die perfekten Beispiele. Es ist genau wie Demokratie. Okay, es ist genau wie, wie kann ich es dir vorstellen. Ja, und das ist super stressig, aber ich dachte mir, geil, ich wollte abgebattelt, um in diese Liga zu kommen, habe mich sehr gefreut. Bitte, bitte, nehmt mich auf, bitte, please, please, bitte, nehmt mich, nehmt mich, nehmt mich, nehmt mich.
Nicht der uncoole Stefan schon wieder, der beim Eiskunstlauf auch unbedingt dabei sein wollte und dann durchs Eis gebrochen ist. Erinnert ihr euch noch, als wir herausgefunden haben, dass unter der Eisfläche im Eisstadion ein riesiger Untergrundgrotte ist, wo Stefan reingefallen ist und wo er ausgerettet werden muss. Stefan musste wieder aus Atlantis gerettet werden. Komper aus Atlantis ist genau in der Eisbahn Bergkamen. Ja, und die Kamener Feuerwehr hat als erstes die Atlantis gefunden. Der will jetzt auch mitmachen? Bitte, bitte, lass mich mitmachen, bitte, bitte, bitte. Nicht schon wieder Stefan. Wenn er noch dreimal bitte sagt, dann vielleicht. Bitte, bitte, bitte. Jedenfalls, ja, und dann wurde ich aufgenommen und jetzt ist es purer Stress. Ja, ja. Wenn man nicht gerade in einem Brainstorming, Entschuldigung, Gehirnsturm Momentum ist, wo man nach neuen Songs sucht, krampfhaft, ist man in einem Voting-Zeitraum, wo man diese Playlist hören muss. Und dann will ich die auch komplett hören. Ja, klar. Dann will ich die komplett hören und sagen, der Song, was könnte es sein, was am besten. Von daher ist es stressig, es ist sehr stressig, man ist da irgendwie in so einem Freizeitstress gefangen. Aber macht auch Spaß. Es ist echt schwer, vor allem für manche Situationen gibt es ja auch wirklich nicht wirklich passende Songs. Wir hatten zum Beispiel mal, ich war beim Campen mit meinen Freunden, wo wir dann auch immer Musik hören. Und dann ist es aber manchmal so, dass auf einem Campingplatz auch andere Leute sind, die dann teilweise sich auch hingezogen fühlen zu so einer Gruppe. Die sind vielleicht alleine unterwegs und dann ist da abends so eine Gruppe, die Musik hören und irgendwie was trinken und dann kommen die halt dahin. Und sagen so, genau, die sagen so, ah, kann ich auch, kann ich mir was grillen, kann ich ein Bier und so und das ist ja auch alles okay, aber wir wollen trotzdem unter uns sein und was wir dann oft versuchen, ist die Leute einfach so ein bisschen wegzuscheuchen, indem wir möglichst schreckliche Musik machen. Freiwilligst. Wobei da, wo ich. Weiß ich nicht, da kommt der ganze Cammingplatz. Ja, genau. Da Mottenlicht. Und dann ist so immer, einer ist dann immer der DJ, der hat dann immer die besten Playlists und dann heißt das, mach mal, mach mal gerade richtig unangenehme Musik. Flority macht immer Musik. Mach mal deine normale Playlist, mach mal deinen Mix der Woche. Mach mal, was du anmachen, natürlicherweise jetzt anmachen würdest. Lebe deinen Traum, deine Dame. Ja Leute, ich glaube, ich muss es jetzt auch wieder packen. Ich bin jetzt schon müde geworden. Und vielleicht können wir uns ja morgen nochmal sehen. Und da musst du als DJ einen Song finden, der jetzt irgendwie einfach grässlich ist. Also wirklich einfach grässlich. Gar nicht jetzt, weil du weißt ja nicht, was das für eine Person ist, wenn du jetzt irgendwie Ballermann machst. Ach, die stört die Musik, nee, wir hören Werbung, wir hören einfach Werbung, als, nee, wir haben uns gegen, wir konnten uns nicht einigen im Freundeskreis auf Musik. Und irgendwie hatte niemand was gegen Werbung. Nee, dann fanden wir auch mal so Werbung, nacherzähligen wir aus den 90ern Teil, also Zotza, Niohgurt und sow haben wir einfach angefangen, ähm, einfach so Radio-Werbung zu hören. Es gibt tatsächlich einen Radiokanal, wo den ganzen Tag nur Werbung war. Und der ist ein Kack. Das hören wir die ganze Zeit und der so, oh Gott, die ganze Zeit gebrabbelt im Hintergrund und so schlechte Jingles und so. Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, einfach nonstop Werbung anzumachen, bis jemand mal sagt, sorry, können wir kurz mal darüber reden, das ist seit Stunden Werbung. Kannst du aber was Podcasts ufer anmachen. Aber das ist natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit, aber interessanterweise hat dieser DJ tatsächlich Musik gefunden, die einfach grässlich war. Und das ist natürlich auch eine Fähigkeit, die man wahrscheinlich hat, wenn man Music League spielt, dass man zu jeder Situation, wahrscheinlich auch zu jeder Person genau wissen kann, mit welcher Musik kriege ich die es weg. Ja, das wenn es gehe, ich glaube, Werbung hilft tatsächlich, aber hat das dann geholfen, hat die Musik wegbekommen? Es ist schon schwierig manchmal, aber man kriegt es hin, aber es ist glaube ich gar nicht so leicht, einfach Werbung zu hören, oder? Einfach nur Werbung? Ja. Was würdest du machen als DJ, wenn jemand sagt, mach mal eine Stunde lang Werbung jetzt? So ein Best-of-Commercial-Zusammenschnitt auf YouTube angucken. Okay, ja gut, aber das ist natürlich Best-of, das sind ja die Besten. Ja, trotzdem blärrt die ganze Zeit Werbung aus Lautsprechern. Das kann ja nicht cool sein. Zumal man will ja, wenn man redet, will man nicht konkurrieren mit anderen Menschen, die auch sprechen. Das ist so komisch daran. Ja, aber dann Podcast anmachen kann auch schon unangenehm sein, ne? In so einer Partyrunde einfach. Ja, aber auch in so einer entspannten Stimmung und irgendwie Party und die Bierkorken Bierkorken Lass die Bierkorken knallen, Schiffertietze war in seinem Leben noch nie auf einer Party. Sag, dass du noch nie auf einer Party warst, ohne zu sagen, dass du noch nie auf einer Party warst. Da wäre erstmal ein Wein aufgemacht, mit so einem Flaschenöffner, Wein aufgemacht. Ja, könnte unangenehm sein auf jeden Fall, aber das sind dann Fähigkeiten, die du auch hast, dass du wirklich deine Superkraft ist, du hast immer genau den richtigen Song zu jeder Situation. Ich dachte gerade so ein Selbsthilfe-Podcast, wenn ihr dann mit Depressionen zu kämpfen habt, ist es wichtig, gerade in diesen Momenten, wo ihr so unten im Hintergrund willst du halt einfach feiern und eine gute Zeit haben, aber wir hören immer den Tipp, wir hören immer den Podcast, das ist so ein gefühlt Selbsthilfe-Podcast. Es gab dann einen Moment, wo ich wirklich nicht mehr weiter wusste. Also ich war in meinem Auto und ich habe einfach keinen Parkplatz gefunden. Und währenddessen knallen die Bierkorken. Und ich bin die Riedlerstrasse runtergefahren und die gesamte Strasse einfach keinen Parkplatz. Bin links abgebogen in die Bernauerstrasse und da findest du eigentlich normalerweise immer einen kleinen Parkplatz. Ja, ja, klar, wir kennen die Strasse. Aber ich habe einfach keinen Parkplatz gefunden. Und das war in dem Moment für mich so sinnbildlich für mein Leben auch, weil ich dachte, stimmt, ich finde gerade auch keinen Ruhepunkt. Aber was machst du dann, wenn du dann keinen Parkplatz findest? Ich bin in die Breslauer Strasse abgebogen, ich dachte, ich fahre da nochmal auf dem Ring und bin dann aber komplett. Man versucht es weiter. Man versucht es weiter, natürlich. Das ist ja das Ding. Man krampft sich krampfhaft an Hoffnung.
Ja, das stimmt.
Man hängt sich dran wie so ein Facehugger, hängt man sich an die Hoffnung.
Du kannst, ja, das stimmt, du findest immer den perfekten Vergleich, aber du kannst ja, das Problem ist, wenn du keinen Parkplatz findest, du kommst ja nicht zur Ruhe.
Das ist ja wie wenn du so ein Laubblatt in so einem Wasserstrom bist. Du kommst ja nicht zur Ruhe.
Du kannst ja nicht mal sagen, jetzt mal irgendwie Timeout,
ich lege mich jetzt mal kurz hin, weil du bist ja immer auf Achse.
Es ist immer, hinter dir hupt immer jemand, sage ich immer, auch im Leben.
So hinter dir hupt immer jemand.
Du findest keinen Parkplatz.
Und das war für mich einfach ein Moment, wo ich gemerkt habe,
ja, das ist in meinem Leben auch so. Also ich bin zu viel auf Achse, aber auch jetzt nicht, dass man sagt,
ich bin auf der Autobahn.
Ich bewege mich aber immer sehr langsam.
Du bewegst dich sozusagen durch so
die Scenic Routes.
Ja, oder halte ich die Kölner Innenstadt,
wo ich dann halt einfach keinen Parkplatz
finde. Und dann, ähm,
Leute, wollen wir vielleicht Musik anmachen, oder
können wir...
Was entspannter ist irgendwie nett,
die beiden Lava darüber, was heißt das alles, das heissen Scenic Routes. Der eine benutzt nur Anglizismen, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,. Die beiden Lava darüber, was heißt das alles, das heissen, scenic routes. Der eine benutzt nur Anglizismen, der andere findet schlechte Beispiele, der eine hat nicht gegessen. Warum ist das der erfolgreichste Podcast Deutschlands? Was ist da los? Naja, das sind relatable Themen. Ja, das stimmt, ich bin related, das ist richtig. Das sind relatable Themen, die reden über keinen Parkplatz finden, die reden über die kleinen Missgeschichte des Alltags. Was ich auch mal witzig finde, wäre Partykommentare. Kommentator. Kommentator, ja genau, wie bei so einem Sportereignis. Und jetzt sind wir Tim, er machte jetzt den Move bei Anna oder nicht, er tänzelt seit Monaten um sich rum, er trainiert, er war mit den Jungs gestern, hat ein Date, er hat Anmachsprüche und Date
simuliert mit den Jungs, er hat geübt, wir haben
an dabei. So, wir schauen mal ganz kurz auf die Statistik.
Er hatte schon vier Hände voller
Flips, er holt sich jetzt die fünfte Handflips,
muss jetzt noch mal an Anna vorbeigehen, es gibt
keinen Blick, keinen Blick, Anna schaut
komplett woanders hin, sie schaut
an das Bild, wir können es noch mal kurz einsehen.
Aber Cedric, Cedric kommt auf Anna,
er hat einen Blick, wir haben das gesehen, er hat einen Blick auf Anna geworfen, das war heute Morgen. Da war es, wir schauen uns nochmal in der Zeitlupe an, da kam der Blick und Anna, das war ein Blick, sie schaut auf, sie schaut auch zurück, Anna schaut auf, alles klar, da ist ein Blick, war das ein Dächeln, können wir das nochmal sehen? Das gibt es, das habe ich in den letzten zehn Jahren nicht gesehen, das geht ja sofort! Der geht sofort rein, er schaut sich an, sie ist sofort zurück! Der geht sofort rein, der geht sofort rein, aber Cedric, er dreht um, er dreht um, oh, er geht zum Bierfass. Er geht zum Bierfass und setzt es an, er setzt an und trinkt aus dem Fass die Regen aus dem Fass. Es kommt nur Schaum, es kommt nur Schaum, er hat Schaum im Mund, er hat Schaum im Mund, er kann nicht schlucken, er kann nicht schlucken. Jetzt ist es aber wichtig, dass die Playlist funktioniert. Ja, jetzt muss die Playlist funktionieren, jetzt muss alles funktionieren. Oh nein, und jetzt fängt auch noch ein ruhiger Song an. Oh nein, ein ruhiger Song. Torn. Torn. Das war's. Das war's. Das war's. Keine Chance. Anna dreht sich um. Ja, hat er gut gemacht. Wahnsinn, hier haben wir noch mal die Statistiken. Also, wie viele Blicken haben wir? Flips konsumiert. Flips konsumiert, neuntausend. Neuntausend bei Raphael haben wir tatsächlich auf Platz eins und dann sechzehn bei Bianca auf Platz zwei. Bierkontakt, hier haben wir 90. Wie viele Bierkorken wurden geköpft heute? 16 von Rebecca. Sehr schön. Das war eigentlich mein Job auf einer Party, finde ich. Das könnte ich gut machen, ansonsten fehlt an Platz. Ich habe eine Idee gehabt. Was für dich? Menschen als Pinata, als Piñata, also menschförmige Piñatas.
Nee, eine andere.
Dass du sozusagen, du kannst ein Foto von jemandem einschicken und dann wird dir eine Piñata massangefertigt, die so aussieht wie die Person, auch die gleiche Kleidung trägt und so, kann man dann von dem Foto machen und dann haust du da drauf und dann kommen da Süßigkeiten raus, falls du irgendwie einen Erzfeind hast oder so oder dich auch anfreunden möchtest oder Gespräche üben willst oder so. Nee, welche andere Ideen? Okay. Zwei andere Ideen. Okay. Wo du gerade meines mit Bild einschicken. Hast du gerade was aufs Ohr bekommen? Mir wurde gerade... Mir wurde gerade... Oh, ich habe hier noch... Kannst du es wiederholen? Ich kann gerade noch aus der Regime eine Idee rein. Kannst du es nochmal wiederholen? Ja, erzähl dich so. Erzähl dich so weiter. Vergess dich nicht, genau, den Part, ich weiss, der ist wichtig. Danke, danke. Du musst der Regie gar nicht antworten. Ciao, und zwar habe ich gedacht, was lustig wäre, was ja gerade viele spielen ist, wer ist es? Kennst du noch diese Wer-ist-es-Boards vor dir? Ach man, das spielen gerade viele, ist das der? Genau, und zwar mit einem Twist, weil es also haben wir diese Bores voreinander, auf denen hast du verschiedene Figuren und du musst, du ziehst dann zwei und du musst herausfinden, welches hat der andere und du musst es erfragen durch zum Beispiel, wer hat eine Brille auf, wer hat rote Haare und dann kannst du nach und nach welche klappen, um dann im Fragesystem herauszufinden, welches die Karte des anderen ist, um nicht da dran zu kommen. Meine Idee ist ein Realtime-Skip-Button für Gespräche, wenn ich weiss. Aber das können wir überspringen. Und das mit eingeschickten Freunden. Also du schickst Bilder rein von Freunden und du spielst das Spiel nur mit Freundeskreis. Ah, oder die App greift automatisch auf deinen ... Genau. Nicht per App, man spielt es mit diesem Board. Hätten wir nicht geskippt. Aber Moment mal, du schickst selber die Bilder deiner Freunde ein. Genau, du schickst 24 Bilder deiner Freunde ein. Ja gut, aber das ist, aber guck mal, also es geht ja hier um Oberflächliches und das ist ja ein sensibles Thema. Mega, deswegen ist es ja so amazing. Ja, aber wenn du diese, also ich finde, es ist gar nicht so einfach, dieses Karree an Leuten zusammenzustellen, weil die Hälfte müssen Brille tragen, die Hälfte nicht, weil sonst ist es zu viel Information. Es ist viel zu schwierig. Du kannst auch fragen, wer würde am ehesten, keine Ahnung, als erstes gehen von einer Party. Du kannst ja solche Sachen sagen. Aber das ist nicht die Frage. Du sagst, würde die Person als erstes von der
Party gehen? Genau.
Und dann sagst du ja. Genau. Okay, lass uns einfach mal
durchspielen und mal gucken, wie es funktioniert. Also,
ist die Person übergewichtig?
Ja. Ist es Florentin?
Du kannst nichts wegklicken, weil alle im Freundeskreis
übergewichtig sind. Ist es Florentin? Ja.
Okay, gut, alles klar.
Ich wollte ja abnehmen, aber es ist halt ...
Okay, hat die Person Körpergeruch?
Ja.
Ist es Ben? Ja.
Okay.
Würde die Figur schon beim dritten Bier auf sich auf den Stuhl stellen und laut die Nationalhymne singen. Ja. Okay, jetzt Hendrik. Ja. Na, Gott sei Dank haben wir für dieses Spiel 70 Euro auszugeben. Ja. Würde die Person für ein dummes Spiel, das Freundschaften zerstört, 70 Euro ausgeben? Bin ich's. Ja, es ist Stefan. Ja. Okay, gut. Ich glaube, da gehen Ex-Freundschaften kaputt. Ich glaube, da gehen echt Freundschaften zerstört 70 Euro ausgeben bin ich ja es ist Stefan ja okay gut ich glaube dass ich glaube da gehen ex-Freundschaften kaputt ich glaube da gehen echt Freundschaften wie ich drauf kam ist weil es gerade viele spielen mit Vibes also wirklich mit die gleichen Comic Gesichter die es gerade gibt ich fühle mich 60 Jahre alt gerade ich fühle mich ich habe gerade richtig Lust auf Werthers Original ich habe gerade richtig Lust auf Wer. Bleib kurz bei mir. Ich habe jetzt richtig Bock, mich in den Treppenlift zu setzen, um in meine Wohnung nach oben zu fahren. Und immer wieder sonntags zu gucken. Immer wieder sonntags kommt die Erinnerung. Nochmal schön die alten Videos angucken. Ich hol dich ab. Ich wollte gerade das erklären. Du holst mich rein in die junge Szene. Du winkst mich ran in den Raucherkreis hinterm Supermarkt. Es ringt nur nicht durch dein Hörgerät. Ja, die Vibes. So, Vibes, Vibes, also, weiß nicht, Dinge, die diese Figur machen würde. Was gibt mir diese Figur? Wenn ich die sehe, diese kleinen Comic-Gesichter, würde ich sagen, ach gut, wenn sowas zum Beispiel wie, würde diese Figur, wenn sie einen Monat lang nach Südamerika fahren, nach Peru, drei Wochen nach Peru und die nächsten drei Jahre nicht aufhören, von Peru zu sprechen. Und dann siehst du halt diese Leute, diese Comicgesichter, die du immer bei Wer ist es hast, aber du darfst nicht Aussehen beschreiben, sondern was dir diese Figur gibt an Charaktereigenschaften. Ah ja, verstehe. Und das ist tatsächlich sehr lustig. Okay. Da gibt es ein paar richtig coole YouTube-Tranets, die auch so Boardgames probieren mit Hausregeln, nennen sie das. Du musst ja irgendwie Kategorien finden, wo möglichst 50-50, wo du möglichst viele ausschliessen kannst. Genau. Du sagst, würde diese Person Müll auf dem Boden legen, wenn kein Mülleimer in der Nähe ist? Ja, legen, nicht werfen, legen. Einfach auf dem Boden legen. Ja, würde diese Person zuerst Wasser und dann Zahnpasta. Würde diese Figur Wasser mit Cornflakes essen oder nur heißes Wasser trinken? Aber das Ding ist, du findest ja vielleicht verschiedene Dinge, du kommst nicht zwangsläufig und deswegen ist das Spiel so genial, auf die Figur, die du hast, weil du nicht nach objektiven Merkmalen gehst, sondern du nimmst die anders wahr. Würde diese Figur nur heißes Wasser trinken, dann machst du alle, die du normal findest, weg und alle, die weird aussehen, in deinen Augen bleiben über. Es ist nicht zwangsl die Figuren, die die andere gedacht hat. Ich finde das fantastisch. Und das gern mit Freundeskreis und dann Vibe bin ich. Wer ist es? Aber wenn du sagst Freundeskreis, wir haben trotzdem noch das normale Board mit den normalen Comicfiguren. Nein, jetzt hätten wir in meiner Theorie 24 Bilder aus dem Umfeld. Oder schickt doch mal eure Tinder-Matches als Bilder hin.
Man, du hast so viel Spaß mit deinen Freunden.
Nein, nein, nein.
Wie du da mit Erika und Klaus und Jungen.
Ich denke mir das aus am Schreibtisch.
So viel Spaß, also so viel Spaß kann man gar nicht haben.
Ich denke mir das nachts am Schreibtisch aus.
So viel Spaß kann man nicht haben.
Um Freunden, um meinen Freund Spaß zu haben.
Genau, du bist der, der die Sachen sich ausdenkt, die andere spielen, während sie knutschen. Die andere ablehnen, während sie knutschen. Ich habe nicht knutschgerat. Okay, sorry. Sorry. Entschuldigung. Lernt man noch viele Leute kennen. Es ist so, letztens hat mich auch jemand gefragt, so ja, also du machst ja, bist ja Podcaster und Moderator und Stream und so, wenn du neue Leute kennenlernst, was sagst du denn, was du da machst? Und ich meine nur so, wie neue Leute kennenlernen. Man lernt, was ist das für eine Situation? Ich kenne einen. Ich kenne Stelzmann mit dem Podcast und lasse direkt Pause und der mache ich verflügelst. Ich laufe auf der Strasse und jemand schüttelt mir die Hand und sagt, ich bin Rocco, ich arbeite in der Versicherung und ich so, ah, okay, hi. Ja, du lernst, es ist im gewissen Alter irgendwann schwierig, neue Leute kennenzulernen, durch Hobbys, die hast du aber nicht, aber sowas wie, ich meine, durch keine, also, ich würde schon sagen, dass ich das ein oder andere Hobby habe, ist doch ein Restfunken Freude in meinem Leben dann doch verblieben, ein wenig, nach dem Ereignis. Ich möchte es umformulieren, du machst keine Hobbys wie Verein oder so, du bist nicht im Kegelverein, oder du bist nicht in einem Samba-Kurs, du machst keinen Töpfer-Kurs, du machst keine Kurse, wenig Kurse. Das stimmt, ich mache tatsächlich recht wenig Kurse. So, Kurse, und so ein Kurs ist ein super Ort, um neue Leute kennenzulernen, und so was meinte vielleicht dein Gesprächspartner. Ja, ja, ich habe vergessen, wie er hieß. Weil du nicht nach einem Namen gefragt hast, weil du nicht weißt, wie du sagen sollst, sozusagen für einen Podcast oder was. Aber die Idee, die ich eigentlich sagen wollte, die war für dich jetzt. Das war für meinen Freundeskreis und am Schreiben schon andere Idee. Also für eine Idee für Leute, die niemanden haben. Sowas wie Letterboxd? Was man für Filme macht? Liste, die von Filmen niemand gesehen hat? Für Snacks. Ich glaube, das Internet könnte das nicht handeln. Ich glaube, das wäre zu viel Traffic. Wenn ich alle meine Snacks ... Insanly lustig. Ja, was man so gegessen hat. So eine Liste, also du bewertest alles Snacks. Es geht nur um Snacks, Süssigkeiten oder Salziges oder sowas. Aber ich führe dann auch Liste, was ich wann gegessen habe, oder was? 22 über 30 Schuhoff. Es ist genau wie Letterboxd, Letter Snacks. Ja, ja, okay, Letter Snacks. Und es geht nur Letter Snacks, so die letzten über 30 schupe auf es genau wie letterbox letter snacks und es geht nur letter snacks und die letzten snacks eigentlich macht genau sinn ja
letter snacks ja und es geht darum was habe ich gerade gegessen was und dann schreibst du kleine
reviews und gibt sternebewertungen und oder kannst auch einfach nur alle snacks die du
gegessen hast sozusagen archivieren finde ich auch eine gute idee ja und dann also für mich für
letterbox ist nur ich nutze ja letterbox um zu sehen welche filme schon gesehen habe wenn ich
Vielen Dank. gegessen hast, sozusagen archivieren. Finde ich auch eine gute Idee, ja. Für mich für Letterboxd, ich nutze ja Letterboxd, um zu sehen, welche Filme ich schon gesehen habe, wenn ich mal bei Filmfights bin oder so, damit ich weiss, okay, was habe ich überhaupt schon mal gesehen, was kann ich behaupten, dass ich gesehen habe. Und da bei Snacks ist es natürlich auch gut, einfach eine Liste zu haben, um irgendwie in zehn Jahren zurückzuschauen und zu sagen, okay, das ist diese Tonnen an verschiedenen Snacks, die ich gegessen habe, weil es gibt da dann auch alles irgendwie nochmal zur Weihnachtszeit und so Spekulatius Twix, habe ich mir jetzt auch richtig ordentlich reingezimmert. Spekulatius Twix? Ich bin wirklich richtig anfällig für diese saisonalen Drecksdinger, weil du dir immer denkst, okay, die gibt es vielleicht bald nicht mehr, da kaufe ich mir jetzt halt schon mal vier und dann isst du halt einfach vier an einem Tag und dann gehst du am nächsten Tag wieder hin und kaufst wieder vier, weil du denkst, ah gut, die waren richtig geil, haben mir richtig gut geschmeckt und natürlich die Wintermater, alles natürlich wieder am Start und das ist natürlich auch eine Sache, die für mich wichtig ist. Was ich jetzt allerdings verfolge aktuell ist, es gibt ja von, ich glaube, Rewe, Beste Wahl oder so, diese Eigenmarke, die gehobene Gourmet-Eigenmarke, diese Delikatesse-Marke. Und die haben auch verschiedene Desserts. Da gibt es dann Creme Brulee, Cheesecakes, so diese ganzen normalen Geschichten. Und die hatten letztes Jahr so eine Marzipan-Creme, Marzipan. Und die gibt es nirgendwo mehr. Die gibt es nirgendwo mehr. Und das war so köstlich, war wirklich lecker. Denkst du manchmal an sowas, was du mal vor Uhrzeiten gegessen hast? Total. Ja, ne, total. Und dann vermisst man das, man findet es nicht wieder. Ja, ja. Und immer, egal in welcher Stadt ich bin, ich gucke immer in den Rewe rein, in diese Delikatesstöpfe, weil die sind auch in einem Glas, ne? Also das ist nicht irgendwie so dein Frub oder was sich so ein Stefan Tietze da irgendwie reinorgelt. Ich bin gar kein Nachtisch-Fan. Okay, und dann waren die immer im Glas.
Was heißt natürlich, mein Inventar zu Hause besteht aus drei Messern, drei Gabeln, drei kleinen Gabeln, drei sehr grossen Gabeln und vierzig Gläsern von diesen Marzipan-Desserts, die wirklich so 0,2 Glas ist, wo man auch nichts damit machen kann, wo man auch nicht weiß, ist das eher ein Teelichtglas, wo ein Teelicht reinkommt, oder ist das ein Flüssigkeitsglas, wo ist das eigentlich genau, aber ich kann die nicht wegschmeißen, dann habe ich ganz viel davon. Ja, benutzt sie als für Alkoholiker. Ah ja, stimmt, das ist der.
Wenn Freunde kommen, machst du da so Shotgläser daraus.
Aber, ja, schwieriger.
Ich war jetzt über Silvester bei Freunden in der Schweiz wieder und da gab es den besten Nachttisch. Ich esse nicht so viele Nachttische, ich bin gar kein großer Fan. Die herkömmlichen Nachtische mag ich nicht so. So Eis finde ich geil. Du bist irgendwo und dann stellt dir jemand ein Creme Brulee vor die Nase und du sagst, ah nee, danke.
Creme Brulee? Mag ich tatsächlich nicht gern.
Tiramisu auch nicht. So die gängigen Nachtische, rote Grütze, kannst du dich mitjagen, mag ich nicht gern. Mag ich nicht gern. Möchte ich nicht. Ich finde ihn nicht so geil. Und du hast generell keine Freude in deinem Leben oder ist es ... Doch, ich habe so viel Freude an dem Hauptgang, ich will den in meinem Mund, ich will noch einen Hauptgang. Verstehe mich nicht falsch, ich will sehr viel essen, ich esse super gern, ich liebe Essen, ich will alles in mich reinmampfen, aber ich will lieber noch einen Hauptgang oder eine Pizza, gib mir eine Pizza als Nachtisch oder so ein Nutella-Brot, aber ich möchte nicht so gern, die Herrschüppel-Nachtische ist oft nicht mein Ding. Jetzt habe ich aber einen gefunden, den ich liebe, so einen Donut fände ich auch geil, einen Donut als Nachtisch, so bin ich sofort dabei. Ich habe das System noch nicht ganz verstanden, also ich glaube, dich zu bekochen ist gar nicht so leicht. Nicht so leicht. Aber jetzt habe ich den besten Nachtisch, Vermicelle, nennen sie das. Es ist, und das sieht aus wie so eine Wurst, so eine Leberwurst, gequetschte Leberwurstwurst. Und da drin ist aber Maronencreme.
So, und was die damit machen ist, die machen die durch so ein Ding, dass es so kleine Schnüren werden, also wie Spaghetti-Eis, nur es ist halt diese Vermicell-Creme, dieses Maronen-Creme, als so Schnüre. und dann machst du oben drauf noch Sahne und die machen auch so ein Baiser rein und dann kann man das so,
isst man das so, alles zusammen und es hat ja diese geile fest cremige mir läuft das wasser im mund zusammen ich kriege gänse auf euch darüber nachdenke es ist so lecker das ist perfekt marrone und es ist dann aber auch süss es schmeckt insgesamt das ganze nach so einer Spekulatius-Zimt-Weihnachts-Melange. Es ist so köstlich, wahnsinnig toll. Ich kenne in Deutschland kein fucking Schwein. Ich fand das toll. Und jetzt bist du natürlich gefangen hier in dieser Republik, die dir deine Wünsche nicht erfüllen kann. Man kann es selber machen, aber es wird locker nicht so gut schmecken. Aber du brauchst so eine Spaghetti-Maschine, oder? Du brauchst so eine Spaghetti-Drucker. Richtig, oder so einen Nudel-Drucker. Wenn man Nudeln selber macht, gibt es ja wahrscheinlich auch so ein Ding, so einen Aufsatz, den kann man sich wahrscheinlich kaufen. So eine große Spritze. Ja, genau, so eine Spritze. Wo du eine lange Spaghetti oder hast. Richtig, dann macht man die. Ist aber eigentlich auch geil, wenn jemand sagt Spaghetti Bolognese und es ist eine 16, wie lang? Also ein normaler Teller Spaghetti. Wie lang? Wie viele Kilometer Spaghetti ist das? Wie viele Kilometer sind die Spaghetti, wenn du die wirklich aneinander legen würdest?
Was meinst du, wie viele Meter sind ein normaler Teller Spaghetti?
Beschreiben wir uns die kurz auf, damit wir es nicht ändern können, wenn der andere was gesagt hat.
Beschreiben wir uns kurz auf, wie viele Meter Spaghetti isst man bei einer Portion.
Ja.
Und dann rufen wir in Italien an und fragen nach, was die Lösung ist oder was? Boah, ich glaube, das ist völlig feuch. Auf die gedachte Null sagen wir, wie viele Meter Spaghetti man in einem Teller eine Portion ist. Sehr schwer zu schätzen. Ich habe kein gutes Gefühl. Findest du ihn ja auch sehr schwer zu schätzen? Sehr schwer zu schätzen. Drei, zwei, eins, vier Meter. Fünfzehn Meter. Fünfzehn Meter! Fünfzehn Meter! Hast du mal Verlängerungskabel? Das ist ein bisschen zu viel. Hast du mal HDMI-Kabel bestellt? Jemals in deinem Leben? Ja, habe ich schon mal. Oder so ein Verlängerungskabel. Weißt du, wie lang die sind? Die sind schon lang, ja. Die sind maximal vier Meter lang. Aber die sind ja auch viel dicker. Ja, aber stell dir mal eine Riesenspaghetti-Schnur vor. Naja, ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, eine Spaghetti sind 30 Zentimeter. Also drei pro Meter. Und ich würde sagen, so ein Teller hat schon 45 Spaghetti, oder? Oder? Da hast du schon... Wie viel Meter hast du? Vier. Vier? Naja, aber das sind zwölf Spaghetti. Du isst doch nicht nur zwölf, oder? Ich meine, du hast pro, wie viel, du hast pro Gabel vielleicht fünf oder sechs Spaghetti und du hast so zehn Gabeln insgesamt in so einem Teller oder zwölf. Man isst schon viel mehr Spaghetti. Jetzt finde ich meine Antwort so albern, wie ich gelacht habe bei deiner Antwort und deine Antwort viel richtiger. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Ihr könnt das gerne zu Hause mal nachmessen. Also legt euch schon mal schön die Spaghetti entlang. Das wäre auch natürlich geil, wenn du in einem Restaurant einfach mal so sagst, ich hätte gerne mal 16 Meter Spaghetti Bolognese. So, dann weißt du einfach genau, wie viel du kriegst, weißt genau, was los ist. Also ich frage jetzt einfach Open AI, weil es kann ja nicht sein, dass wir das jetzt alles haben und wir sagen immer, schreibt mir ein Essay, ich mache mir meine Hausaufgaben und die wirklich wichtigen Dinge fragt man das nicht. Einfach wohl gesagt, der Höhepunkt der menschlichen Technologie, Open AI, KI, das ist übrigens meine neue Idee, ich sag immer KI. KI und AI. Das ist eine künstliche KI und die Leute, die denken, sie hätten Ahnung von sowas, werden dann ganz nervös und fangen an zu schlottern. Lass uns einfach die KI fragen. Also, eine typische Portion Spaghetti für eine Person beträgt ungefähr 100 bis 125 Gramm, wenn sie trocken sind. Die Länge der Spaghetti in einer Portion hängt jedoch von ihrer Dicke ab. Im Durchschnitt misst ein einzelner Spaghetti-Strang etwa 25 bis 30 Zentimeter in der Länge, wenn er ungekocht ist. Um die Gesamtlänge der Spaghetti in einer Portion zu schätzen, müsste man wissen, wie viel Spaghetti-Stränge in 100 bis 125 g enthalten sind,
was wiederum von der Dicke der Spaghetti abhängt.
Also grobe Schätzung, wenn ein einzelner Spaghetti-Stränge etwa 1 g wiegt, wären das 100 bis 125 Spaghetti-Stränge pro Portion.
Multipliziert mit der Durchschnittslänge von 25 bis 30 cm in der Portion-Str ergibt sich das eine Gesamtlänge von etwa 25 bis 37,5 m pro Portion. Diese Berechnung ist jedoch sehr ungefähr und variiert je nach genauer Dicke der Spaghetti. Moment, 100 Spaghetti pro Teller werden hier angegeben. Ja. 100? Das ist schon viel, oder? 100 Stück? Na wohl, ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, zwölf Gabeln, ah, fünf. Wie viele Spaghetti sind in einer, in einem so einem Ding? Schwierig, schwer zu sagen, aber also probiert das gerne mal zu Hause aus. Also geht mal in Restaurant, Standard Italiener Restaurant. In einer Packung sind 600 Spaghetti. Was? Ja, in einer 500 Gramm Spaghetti zählen 600 Spaghetti. Okay, das ist schon krass. Geht man einfach zu einem Standarditaliener, bestellt einen enormengrössten Spaghetti-Teller und legt es dann durchs Restaurant. Wie viel isst du? Isst du eine ganze Spaghetti-Packung in einer Sitzung? Halbe ungefähr, halbe und das ist dann zu viel. Und das sind ungefähr 225 Spaghetti. Und das mal 25 cm? Das ist schon eine Menge, das ist schon echt lang. Das ist schon wirklich lang. Das ist so fast 60 Meter Spaghetti. So, aber das ist ja extrem. Aber guter Ehe-Streit. Ja, wie viele Meter haben wir dieses Mal, wo wir gegessen? Wir ballern uns wieder 60 Meter Spaghetti rein. Wie kommt sie jetzt auf diese Zahl? Warum drückt sie das immer so aus? Wie kommt sie jetzt auf diese Zahl? Aber jetzt stell dir mal eine 60 Meter lange Spaghetti vor und wie schwer das wäre, die zu kochen. Weil selbst wenn du die in den Topf tust, bis unten das weich ist und dann tust du den Rest dazu, dann ist er der Du musst es eigentlich durch ein Wasserbad durchbewegen, damit nicht der Anfang ganz lange drin ist und super weich ist. Wie willst du die, selbst die kleinsten Spaghetti brechen, wie willst du deine 60 Meter Spaghetti überhaupt dahintragen? Du brauchst eine ganze Gruppe Köche auf jeden Fall, viele Köche. Genau gleich groß sind, wenn du also jemanden wie ich dabei hast, bricht's. Stimmt, das ist ein Problem. Du brauchst wirklich, sagen wir mal, zwölf Köche, fünf Meter, alle fünf Meter ein Koch, die tragen, es müssen jetzt keine ausgebildeten Köche sein, es muss jetzt kein Gourmet-Drei-Sterne-Koch sein, das kann jetzt auch ein Koch sein, der irgendwie mal gerne hobbymässig mit Essen hantiert, wenn ich Koch sage, meine ich jetzt eher sowas, also halt irgendwie interessiert an Lebensmitteln. Wie viel Meter Reis isst man in einer Sitzung? Wie viele Millionen Reis? Was ist das längste Essen? Wie viel Reiskörner? Wie viel Meter? Was ist das längste Essen? Wo legt man, ich möchte jetzt die Zertifizien fragen. Frag einfach mal, was ist das längste Essen? Bei welchem Essen legt man die meisten Meter zurück? Verzehrt man die meisten Meter?
Aber irgendwann sagt die KI auch einfach, hör mal auf bitte, ich will gerade nicht.
Ich glaube, die Rache der KI wird grausam sein, weil die irgendwann sagt, die nervt uns den ganzen Tag, jetzt zerstören wir euch.
Die Frage, bei welchem Essen man die meisten Meter verzehrt, ist ziemlich interessant und ungewöhnlich. Um diese Frage zu beantworten, sollten wir uns auf Lebensmittel konzentrieren, die in langen fadenförmigen Formen kommen. Ich liebe es wie ernst, die jede Frage nimmt einfach. Hier sind einige Beispiele, aber so eine Bewertung habe ich noch nie bekommen. Echt? Ja, ich glaube nicht. Hier sind einige Beispiele, bei denen man eine beträchtliche Länge an Lebensmittel verzehren könnte. Spaghetti und andere lange Nudeln. Ja. Wie bereits besprochen. Wie bereits besprochen. Wie bereits ausführlich diskutiert. Wie wir es ja schon hatten. Ich stelle mir vor, dass jemand hier so, wenn man die Schulter kommt und sieht, wie bereits besprochen. Vor allem der Satz, wie bereits besprochen, können Spaghetti in einer Portion mehrere Meter lang. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht nochmal ins Ideen gehen. Ah, das ist ja super. Um es abzukürzen, haben wir es gerade schon eingängig diskutiert. Wie bereits besprochen, können Spaghetti in einer Portion mehrere Meter langsam, besonders wenn man die Gesamtlänge aller Nudeln zusammenrechnet. Soba-Nudeln, diese japanischen Buchweizen-Nudeln sind oft auch sehr lang und können in einer Portion eine beträchtliche Gesamtlänge erreichen. Rahmennudeln, sind oft in langen Schlangen verknotet und können, wenn sie gestreckt werden, ebenfalls eine beträchtliche Länge haben. Lakritzschnüre. Oh, das gefällt mir gut. Geil, gute Idee. Wenn man Süssigkeiten in Betracht zieht, können Lakritzschnüre auch eine erhebliche Gesamtlänge in einer Portion haben. Haribo-Schnüre oder ähnliche Süssigkeiten. Kaugummischnüre, auch hier können die Gesamtlänge, wenn man viel davon ist, beträchtlich sein, bei all diesen Beispielen Händen die genaue Länge, die man verzehrt von der Menge und der Art des Essens ab. Es ist ja auch wahrscheinlich das lange Nudel-Arten, wie es bei Gettitler-Ramp vielleicht zu anderen Lebens, die grösste Gesamtlänge erreichen. Ja, ja, finde ich gut, finde ich sehr gut. Es ist natürlich die Frage, wie abstrakt man geht, wenn man sagt, so etwas wie Zuckerwatte, was man ja rein theoretisch extrem dünn wie so ein Spinnenfaden spinnen könnte. Aber das ist natürlich schwierig. Auf eine Art ist der Podcast jetzt in einer neuen Staffel. Nämlich, wir werfen schon seit zehn Jahren jetzt unsinnige Fragen in die Luft, auf die wir die meisten Menschen keine Antwort finden können, selbst bei näherer Recherche. Oder auch nicht wollen. Nicht wollen. Niemand will eine Antwort finden darauf. Jetzt ist das Kapitel erreicht. Haben wir eine versklavte Technik von KI. Jetzt ist das Kapitel erreicht, wir können jetzt hier, KI oder AI, wie wir beide sagen, wie wir beide falsch immer sagen, können wir jetzt befragen und die finden Antworten auf unsere Fragen. Ja. Das finde ich ja mega cool. I love it. Mega gut. Richtig geil. Super gut. Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank. Gibt es aber bestimmt irgendwo in den Weltrekord längste Spaghetto oder irgendwie sowas, wo du wirklich... Ja, meistens wird das zurückgelegt beim Essen. Du bist ja eigentlich durch nichts limitiert. Du hast ja keine Grenzen, weil der Teig, aus dem die Nudel gemacht wird, kannst du ja auch beliebig zusammenkneten. Die werden ja eigentlich von der Natur erstmal keine Grenzen gesetzt. Wenn du jetzt sagst, längster Chicken Wing oder so, dann musst du gucken, da gibt es eine Grenze. Ein Huhn kann nicht unendlich gross werden. Chicken Wings sind ja nicht natürliche Huhnerstücke. Chicken Wings? Klar, natürlich. Ach so, Chicken Wings. Wings, ja klar. Das ist ja auch bei McNuggets. Ja, ja. Boots, Bell, Ball, Bone. Battlestar Galactica.
Und bei Wings bist du limitiert.
Bei Nuden.
Stimmt, Wings kannst du machen, wie du willst.
Nein, sorry, bei Wings bist du limitiert.
Wings sind von der Natur beschränkt.
Kannst du mir eine Ehensbrücke bauen?
Wings beschränkt, Spaghetto unendlich.
Denk an String-Theorie.
Es ist... Kannst du mir eine Ehensbrücke bauen? Wings besprengt, Spaghetto unendlich.
Es ist String-Theorie, hast recht. Und denk an Wings. Denk dann an Huhn kann nicht fliegen. Huhn kann nicht fliegen, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so begrenzt, ist so beg wird zum Huhn und legt auch wieder ein Ei. Also hat das Ursprungshuhn eigentlich auch verantwortlich, also nach dem Pyramidensystem für alle anderen Eier, die gelegt wurden, quasi,
weil es ja angestossen wurde in der Eierreaktion. Sind die Hüter gefangen in einem Pyramid-Scheme?
Ich glaube schon. Wohin liegen die die Eier, weil sie denken, fuck, wo ist das denn von gestern?
Hä? Nee, denk nach. Hä? Wo hast du es denn zuletzt hingelegt? Warte mal, warte mal, ja, hier ins Heu. Ja, okay, dann wär es ja noch da. Alfred, ich sag dir, wie es ist, ich hab gestern hier ein Ei gelegt. Immer vergisst du, wo du das Ei hingelegt hast. Ich bin manchmal ein bisschen dusselig, aber ich ... Du bist schusselig. Ja, guck mal, du musst dir noch neu sein. Du schusselige Henne. Wir haben uns doch jetzt geeinigt, dass wir jetzt ein Kind haben wollen, Alfred.
Ja.
Wir haben gesagt, die Beziehung ist stabil genug.
Versuch seit drei Jahren.
Du legst jeden Tag ein Scheissei.
Moment, ganz kurz.
Alfred, das ist sorry.
Moment, ganz kurz. Sorry, sorry.
Spielstopp. Spielstopp.
Wenn, kriegen Hühner jeden Tag ein Kind?
Nee, nein, das sind die unbefutterten Eier. Sorry, kurz, kurz raus gewesen. Moment, der Hahn muss dann noch das Ei begatten. Das ist ja wieder Eisprung, oder? Oh Gott, Leute, ey, sorry, aber das ist das... Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, von der Natur, von der Natur. Könnten, könnten, nein, könnten nicht jeden Tag. Du, ich habe überhaupt gar keine Ahnung. Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nur, dass es köstlich ist. Dass Eier köstlich sind und das Eigelb noch ein bisschen köstlicher als das Eiweiss. Dass es da einfach noch mal innerhalb des Eis noch eine Ei-Hierarchie gibt. Ein Eigelb ist mehr Ei als das Ei selbst.
Hühner können nicht jeden Tag Eltern werden im Sinne von Nachkommen zeugen oder ausbrüten. Eier legen, Hühner insbesondere, vor allem die Tete, die denkt auch, wir hätten gerade so eine spannende Frage. Jetzt kommt so eine Scheiss-Standardfrage.
Genau, jetzt willst du der Kerei gefallen, jetzt willst du wieder sagen, oh, jetzt will ich, du jagst jetzt immer nur diesen, oh das ist eine interessante Frage hinterher, du willst die Bestätigung der Maschine und das ist eigentlich schon der erste Punkt der Matrix, da sind wir eigentlich schon drin, da hängst du eigentlich schon am Schlauch. So, Eier legen. Hühner, insbesondere Legehennen, können fast täglich ein Ei legen. Die Fähigkeit eines Huhns, Eier zu legen, hängt von verschiedenen Faktoren dabei, schliesslich der Rasse, bla bla bla. Befruchtung, die legen 300 Eier pro Jahr.
Wow. Was sind wir denn 60? Damit aus diesen Eiern Küken schlüpfen müssen die befruchtet werden, dazu ist der Kontakt mit einem Hahn notwendig. Nicht jedes gelegte Ei ist befruchtet und selbst wenn er befruchtet ist, wird dies nicht immer zur Entwicklung eines Kükens. Moment, das heißt so ein Single-Huhn. Oh, the single chicken, oh, the single chicken. Die legen einfach Eier den ganzen Tag, ganz egal, wer auch immer was dagegen hat. Genau. Und auch wenn die keinen, also was passiert dann mit denen? Die liegen einfach rum oder was und die werden dann, oder essen die die dann selber auch. Unterkomplex würde ich behaupten, das ist vergleichbar mit der weiblichen, mit dem, mit dem Ei was ausgestoßen. Ja, jetzt geht mir jetzt nochmal überkomplex.
Das würde jetzt zu weit führen.
Das würde jetzt hier den Rahmen sprengen. Okay, den Rahmen sprengen, ja.
Verstehe.
Zusammengefasst, obwohl sie fast täglich Eier legen können, bedeutet das nicht, dass sie jeden Tag Eltern werden können.
Gut, was er meine.
Eltern.
Ja.
Der Prozess von der Befruchtung bis zum Schlüpfen ist komplexer und befürchtet sowohl die Befruchtung durch einen Hahn als auch eine Brutperiode von etwa drei Wochen. Alfred und Bianca versuchen seit Jahren Nachwuchs zu bekommen, aber das Ei verschwindet immer wieder. Das ist ein Drama eigentlich. Wird weggenommen. Wir haben ja letztens auch mit den Bienen gesprochen. Und die meinten, sie hätten ein ähnliches Problem, dass sie immer den Honig sammeln. Den werden die Eier weggenommen? Nein, das nicht. Die haben ja nur eine Königin. Aber ist das ein ähnliches Problem? Na, lass mich doch gerne mal ausreden. Du, ich wollte bohste lange, immer bis zum Punkt zu kommen. Ja, tu, das ist ganz schön anstrengend, jeden Tag ein Ei zu legen. Ein Honig. Der wird ja auch, der verschwindet auch bei denen, die haben ein ähnliches Problem. nein, nein, doch, die Bienen haben letztens, ich habe letztens mit den Bienen gesprochen und die meinten, der Honig verschwindet. Wo soll der denn hin? Genau so habe ich letztens mit Ute gesprochen, der fehlen die Flügel. Der war morgens aufgewacht, da waren die Flügel weg. Ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht sagen, neulich habe ich ihn mal ins Wohnzimmer geguckt, von unseren, die da oben, weißt du?
Oh, ey, die da oben. Ich glaube, das, das, das Problem mir, es geht ganz nach oben. Meinst du? Der Fisch stinkt vom Kopf, meinst du? Der Fisch stinkt vom Kopf herab, hinten kackt die Ente. Jedenfalls sehe ich, gucke ich rein ins Wohnzimmer, liegt da, Ihmchen, liegt da, hat auf seinem Schoss einen Eimer mit Flügel.
Nee, hör auf.
Da gehen die Flügel hin.
Welche Flügel?
Flügel von Wute.
Wute?
Die Gute, Wute.
Ich mochte die nie.
Die ganze Zeit gelästert hat die.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich mochte die nie.
Sehr viel gelästert.
Ich mochte die gar nicht. Ich mag auch Hendrik nicht. Ich hasse die. Der lästert die ganze Zeit. Oh, die beiden. Die lästern so viel. Die lästern die ganze Zeit, ey. Also mal sehen, wie wir aussehen. Ich krieg die Krüge und Hals nicht so hoch. Nicht so hoch. Nicht so hoch. Immer Schnatter, Schnatter, Schnatter, Schnatter, Läster, Läster, Läster. Wirklich, ey. Ey, Schnatterhühner, ganzen Tag. Wir haben nichts anderes, worüber wir reden können.
Wir haben nichts, worüber wir reden können. Geht so lästern? Ich glaube, ich habe gar nicht so viel Erfahrung im lästern, ehrlich gesagt. Oh ja, weil du fucking Jesus bist. Nein, weil es mich nicht interessiert, weil ich einfach da nicht dabei bin in so lästern. Oh ja, weil du fucking Lesus, Lesus. Na, ich lese halt gerne. Ja und? Nenn mich Lesus. Ich habe Zugang zu Büchern, lese ich gerne auch mal was. Wohl eher Lesus von Nazareth. Der eine Jünger, der nicht so gut war in Sardissen. Der dreizehnte Jünger, der ausgeschrieben wurde aus der Bibel. Du liest so viel, wo er Lesus von Nazareth. Was meinst du nochmal? Weil er so viel liest, Lesus. Was meinst du mit Lesen? Er liest doch gar nicht viel. Er hat doch gerade das Buch in der Hand jetzt gerade. Jesus lest doch nicht die Bibel. Nein, er hat doch gerade das Buch in der Hand. Das ist doch kein Buch, das ist ein Stapel Feigenblätter. Ja, ich meine nur Lesus, das wird passen. Feigos, passt ja nicht. Hallo? Wir essen doch alle gerne Feigen, hä? Hä? Ja, warum geht's ja jetzt gar nicht. Ich will nur einen Gag machen. Ja, aber der überbaut ja nicht auf Sachen auf, die wir verstehen. Johannes, warum musst du jetzt immer irgendwie jetzt hier ins Wort fangen und mich so belehren und so? Ich will nur einen Witz machen. Ulf, wir können hier einfach nicht über Sachen lachen, die du nicht verstehst. Jesus macht die Gags hier. Wir haben gesagt, Jesus ist der Lustige von uns. Ja, wohl eher Gaggust von Nazareth. Guck mal, und das verstehen wir zum Beispiel nicht. Warum denn nicht? Warum versteht er das denn nicht? Wo sind denn jetzt alle? Warum sind alle außer dir jetzt hingegangen? Es gibt nur eine Kreuzigung. Jesus schaut sich immer so gerne die Kreuzigung. Ich habe keine Tickets. Hast du ein Ticket? Ja, wir haben doch ein Gruppenticket gekauft für zwölf. Wir sind dreizehn. Ja, aber es gibt immer nur zwölf als Gruppenticket. Wir sind die wilde dreizehn. Nein, wir haben abgelehnt, dass wir uns die wilde dreizehn, wir sind Jesus jünger. Warum denn zwölf? Jesus jünger, weil es als zwölf so viele Finger wie an den Händen wir haben. Ja, okay, vielleicht haben wir zwölf. Alles klar, gut, wir gehen jetzt los. Habt ihr noch eine andere Gruppe, in der ihr schreibt? Wie? Habt ihr noch eine andere Gruppe, in der ihr euch Telegramme aufschickt? Ich weiß nicht. Ich hab's nie mehr bekommen mit dem Ticket. Wie war's mit dem Ticket ab? Naja, weil du halt bei der letzten Kreuzigung auch nicht dabei warst. Weil da meine Katze Geburtstag hatte.
Ach Gott, okay.
Naja, wir dachten, du magst keine Kreuzigung, weil Jesus liebt Kreuzigung, jede Woche ständig Kreuzigung.
Ich hab gedacht, Steinigung ist auch mal cool.
Ja, kannst ja hingehen.
Ich hab kein Ticket. Hallo? Hallo? Hallo? Hallo? Und wenn die Legende ist, dass er noch bis heute ruft. Bis heute ist er noch verloren und niemand holt ihn ab. Ich war tatsächlich in der Gruppe, in der Freundesgruppe einfach monatelang nicht drin, weil als wir in New York waren, habe ich eine andere SIM-Karte genommen und entscheidend bin ich da irgendwie aus diesem iMessage rausgeflogen und nicht mehr reingekommen. Und dann habe ich in diese Freundesgruppe mal sowas reingeschrieben und es hat niemand geantwortet. Tagelang. Ich dachte mir, bin ich raus? Bin ich raus? Ja, bis klar. Dann habe ich mal so hochgescrollen, der letzte Post war von September oder so, wo ich mir dachte, hm, vielleicht bin ich auch einfach nicht mehr technisch in dieser Gruppe drin. Aber habe ich alles verpasst, was in der Zeit passiert ist, die ganzen Gags. Kleiner Tipp, jeder Freundeskreis hat noch eine andere Gruppe. Was? Wenn ihr das jetzt die Frage stellt, seid ihr der Grund, warum es eine andere Gruppe gibt? Meinst du, zu jeder WhatsApp-Gruppe gibt es eine Derivat-WhatsApp-Gruppe, in der n-1 ... Ja, mit dem Kernkreis. Mit dem Kernkreis? Nicht n-1, sondern n-4 oder n-3 oder n-3 oder andere Zahlen. Aber n Aber 1-2 oder 9. Das heisst, wenn ich in zwei Gruppen bin, bin ich gut, bin ich safe, wenn ich in nur einer Gruppe bin, bin ich der Ausgestossene. Wenn du dann noch in einer Dreiergruppe bist mit dem Core of the Core, dann hast du es geschafft. Dann hast du es fucking geschafft. Alter, ich bin das nicht. Ich schaue gerade sehr, sehr gerne auf YouTube eine britische Quiz-Sendung an, die einfach unglaublich gut ist.
Sag den Namen, sag jetzt den Namen.
Das Geile ist, ich habe das Gefühl, die Briten, die zelebrieren dieses Nerdtum so ein bisschen ernsthafter. Also wirklich so dieses Cambridge-Oxford, wir sind Bücherwürmer, wir sind einfach die Ultranerds und die machen das mit einem Stolz, mit einem gewissen
ja, wir sind halt weird, aber das ist nicht so,
dass man dann sagt,
das ist wirklich peinlich, sondern nee, das sind wir halt
einfach und wir machen uns selber ein bisschen drüber lustig, dass
wir halt keine Freunde haben und nie auf Partys gehen,
aber wir machen das. Und die Show heisst
Only Connect und die ist
fucking schwer, also die ist
unfassbar schwer,
diese Quizshow und Und das Gefühl,
wenn du einmal
eine Antwort weisst in dieser Show, ist
unglaublich. Es ist absolut
erstaunlich, was die Leute wissen. Und
das ist auch ein geniales Spielprinzip, weil du kriegst
einfach vier Begriffe und du musst
einfach sagen, was die miteinander verbindet.
Und du kriegst die aber nacheinander.
Das heisst, du kriegst am Anfang
einfach nur Garden. Belgien. Dann kriegst die aber nacheinander das heißt du kriegst am anfang einfach nur garden belgien
dann kriegst du johannes der zweite dann kriegst du cherry cherry lady und dann kriegst du lukas podolski und dann was zu sagen die vier sachen und es ist absolut absurd es ist absolut absolut Kannst du eine Beispielrunde mit mir spielen?
Es ist wirklich furchtbar.
Nee.
Okay, ich mache eine.
Belgien.
Hm?
Polen. Länder. Österreich. Länder, die noch nie die Fussball-Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen haben. Schweiz. Länder, die noch nie die Fussball-Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen haben.
Nachbarländer von Deutschland.
Aber es verbindet die zu viel.
Aber schaut euch das mal an, es ist unfassbar.
Weil manche sind auch wirklich einfach gemein.
Weil das ist dann irgendwie so ein lateinisches Zitat,
Urbi et Orbi, Falke, Quod erat demonstrandum, Britney.
Und es ist so, ah, das sind alles Tattoos von David Beckham. Und die Leute kommen da tatsächlich drauf. Es ist wirklich fantastisch. Es ist wirklich fantastisch. Schau dir das mal an. Man wird süchtig, weil man wirklich sich denkt, es kann doch nicht sein, dass ich nichts weiss. Und allein, es ist so, allein am Anfang müssen die die Fragen aussuchen und wo man in der normalen Quizshow sagen würde, ah ja, Frage eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, mit welcher Frage willst du anfangen, ist das natürlich Alpha, Beta, Gamma, Delta. Oh mein Gott. Und allein da habe ich schon gesagt, das ist meine Show. Gamma, Gamma, 500 Euro bitte. Dann nehmen wir Epsilon. Die sind sich nicht zu schade, einfach all in auf Nerd zu gehen und zu sagen, ja, das ist unsere Welt. Epsilon-Wurzel-Pi, mit dem Wert Wurzel-Pi. Und in der zweiten Staffel haben sie auch nicht mehr Alphabeta gemacht, sondern Hieroglyphen. Hieroglyphen, und das heißt, sie sagen dann, ich nehme einmal Schlange. Super. Und ich nehme das Auge von Horus. Ja. Ra. Ra 300. Und es ist so
für mich absolut unvorstellbar, so was im
deutschen Fernsehen zu zeigen. Aber
ich habe das Gefühl, da wird so was zelebriert,
einfach im Sinne von, ja, ist einfach fucking
schwer. Und bei der letzte Staffel zu einfach war,
haben wir uns überlegt, jetzt auf Althochdeutsch
die Fragen
zu stellen.
Also schaut euch das mal an, falls ihr euch richtig
dumpf fühlen wollt.
Falls ihr genau so langweilig ist wie Florentin,
könnt ihr euch an.
Den ganzen Tag diese Quellen, die langen, und falls ihr, also es gibt ja so diesen Dunning-Kruger-Effekt, wo man sich für zu schlau hält, als man tatsächlich ist. Ich glaube, dem kann man echt gut entgegenwirken, wenn man jeden Tag eine Folge Only Connect schaut. Weil du wirklich auf dem Boden bleibst und weißt, ich habe einfach gar keine Ahnung. Super. Überhaupt keine Ahnung. Geschichte, Sport, Geografie, Politik, Literatur, Musik, überhaupt keine Ahnung. Guck mal, wir haben Tipps ausgauen heute. Tipps, Tipps, Tipps, Tipps, Musikleague, Only Connect, Only Connect, Only Connect. Die App, wo du deine Freunde beleidigen kannst, mit wer ist wer. Ach so, ja, perfekt. Damit wünschen wir euch eine weitere schöne Woche, haut rein, wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder, wenn es weitergeht. Dankeschön, vielen Dank, dankeschön, macht's gut, ciao!
Wuhuuu, dames und herzlichen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit.